it's getting harder and harder for
Democrats to ignore Hunter's Buffet of
corruption and for Republicans to resist
impeaching Joe Biden over it the White
House making a major change to its story
on what President Biden knew about
hunter's foreign business deals it used
to be that Gramps was always in the dark
about everything
I did not know he was on the board of
that company I've never discussed my
business or their business my sons or
daughters but I never discussed a single
thing with my son about anything having
to do with the crane I've never spoken
to my son about his overseas liar but
then we found out that an ex-biz partner
of the first son said that Hunter threw
his dad on speakerphone at least 24
times during the Shady business talks
and just like that the White House
shifted the goal posts curious at the
White House
and spoken to his son
so I've been I've been asked this
question a million times the answer is
not going to change the answer Remains
the Same the president had was never in
business with his son I just don't have
anything else to add
with the evidence piling up house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy is toying with
the big I word
this president has also used something
we have not seen since Richard Nixon use
the weaponization of government to
benefit his family and deny Congress the
ability to have the oversight I believe
we will follow this all the way to the
end and this is going to rise to an
impeachment inquiry the way the
Constitution tells us to do this and we
have to get the answers to these
questions
and here's a delicious side dish to the
buffet of corruption remember Hunters
blow straw art well he's reportedly
raking in the cash on that to the tune
of at least 1.3 million dollars one of
the buyers was a democratic donor friend
whom dad named to a prestigious
commission that's just a coincidence of
course judge that happens all the time
so I'm not a big fan of the impeachment
thing but you know I'm why not at this
point you know here's the thing I mean
we've got to put some kind of Moral
Moral imprimatur that this is wrong the
truth is an impeachment is not going to
end up convicting them of anything uh
that that this deserves a real criminal
prosecution you know for the longest
time everyone kept saying well what
business are they in what business are
they in the business is the business of
Joe Biden and from the beginning
everyone was concerned about Hunter
Biden and brisma I've got some articles
here uh they express concern to Obama
and 2015 deputy secretary of state
expressed concerns to the Obama White
House they weren't everybody in
Washington knew and yet and and Joe's
family knew Hunter the brother the other
brother everybody who got a bank account
and a deposit knew everybody in the
world knew but Joe Biden didn't know but
here's the thing when you've got a
situation where there is an
investigation okay and it's a shame it's
got to be conducted by Congress and not
the Department of Justice because we
know based upon what we saw with Hunter
the Department of Justice is not fair it
is not objective then what they've got
to do is they've got to go down this
road and what's the point Greg of going
down the road without impeaching guy and
let me just say a couple other things
I've investigated these kinds of crimes
my office has prosecuted them this is an
organized criminal Enterprise where they
engage in a common scheme or plan the
common schemer plan repeats itself where
Hunter goes in gets a job because they
need the father Joe can say I had no
idea what was going on except for the
fact that he flew them uh flew his son
on Air Force two except for the fact
that he showed up at meetings except for
the fact that he was on the phone 24
times except for the fact that there's
this oligarch who has 10 million dollars
who has Joe Biden on his on a cell phone
hopefully he won't end up dead somewhere
now Hunter Biden is a thug I don't know
why he's even in the white house I don't
understand uh why we're even talking
about this guy and I want to say finally
Joe Biden is moving the Gold Club goal
post from I know nothing about my son
too he's never been in business you know
it is is it disingenuous and the country
knows it and uh one last thing
on the on the art okay this is the quote
the president has established the
highest ethical standard of any
Administration in American history and
his family is committed to that yeah
yeah you know Dana this has all the
ingredients you love in the story sex
drugs corruption art
isn't it weird how the media has no
interest in this I mean this is like the
perfect this is like the best summer
story because it's real there was a
crack in the dam yesterday a little
crack in the dam and it was uh Peter
Baker at the New York Times tweeting
about the communications change the
language change at the White House
briefing whether it was inadvertent or
not maybe Karen Jean-Pierre thought she
was saying the exact same thing but I
doubt it because there is a distinction
between
Joe Biden never discussed business with
Hunter to Joe was never in business with
his son reporters who are paying
attention and apparently some of them
are recognized that's different and so
now you have wouldn't you have a little
crack in the day I'm like that reporters
can start chiseling away if they want I
also wonder where is the Senate on this
the Senate Democrats you know the
busload who are demanding Clarence
Thomas resign because he has a rich
friend yeah that's right right where's
Sheldon White House yeah is that white
like Sheldon White House is leading the
charge of Glenn's Clarence Thomas
because he thinks things are corrupt
well you you've seen Hunter's art okay
is it worth 1.3 million dollars oh if so
to a major Democratic donor who wants to
be appointed to a board it might be
worth 1.3 million dollars and no one
else would have gotten away with that
well Jesse as you know I'm your Rich
friend
but you'll get nothing for me does it
bother you that uh painters like the
great painters of the world like Van
Gogh or Renoir or Bob Ross they died
broke the only person I know who you
just named was Bob Ross and I'm not even
I'm not even true any of that and if you
guys said
I think it's Renoir
yeah okay okay what about van Gogh yes
is that the guy that lost the ear yes
yes nailed it yes don't ask me any more
art questions please well now you just
know there's a way for the donor you
don't have to donate to the campaign you
can just pay the family directly right
what a workaround
I had to write this down because this is
so important I didn't want to miss a
line
arly
[Laughter]
to put it simply this is the business
they were in this is a dirty foreign
lobbying shop Joe was the chief and they
were selling access influence and policy
I love the Democrats now saying they
have not tied this to Joe Biden oh
really okay so Joe Biden's on the phone
with Hunter's business partners he's in
meetings and dinners with Hunter's
business partners Hunter's business
partners are visiting Joe Biden at the
White House Hunter's business partners
all coincidentally call him the big guy
Hunter's business partners and Hunter
are flying on Air Force 2 with Joe Biden
Biden's policy portfolio jives exactly
with Hunter Biden's portfolio Hunter is
shaking down business partners with Joe
Biden in the room informants are saying
Joe Biden was bribed and Hunter's
business partners saying they're holding
10 for the big guy so a few questions if
Joe Biden is so clean Jessica
why'd the CIA lie to the voters before
the last election about the laptop why
did the FBI censor the laptop why were
RSS IRS investigators prevented from
pursuing leads against Joe Biden why'd
the Biden family constantly get tipped
off why were search warrants blocked why
do you set up two dozen shell companies
if you have a legitimate business
actually what is the Biden family
business
no one can answer that question so Joe
Biden if 10 Biden family members take 17
million dollars from overseas what was
the money for no one can answer that
question why is every Chinese business
partner in with the bidens missing or in
prison why are all Hunters American
business partners either in prison or
awaiting sentencing okay
why is the Romanian business partner
facing charges why is the Mexican
business partner facing charges why is
the Ukrainian business partner on the
lamb also facing charges Jessica can you
answer any of those questions I think
Jesse I think you have a new segment on
your show called why why yes I'm not
done I'm pulling the judge you need and
one more thing
Comer only has two bank records there's
nine more are you willing to go down
with this ship Devin Archer is about to
testify what happens when the bride
takes leap a month before the next
election are they going to cover those
up too what happens when they find the
10 they're holding for the big guy and
Jimmy Biden's shell company in Delaware
what happens you're just connecting the
dots I know someone has to yeah you know
Jessica
I love what you said in the green room
we were we were sitting there uh
discussing our favorite books and you
said uh with that 1.3 million dollars it
would be great if if Hunter announced
all that money would go to his baby
daughter and I thought that was so nice
of you
art deal the big scoop admits that it
doesn't know if Hersh naftali that's her
name last name who bought the piece did
it before or after she got the
appointment but it was a democratic
donor it's definitely a favor to the
family but she got an appointment that
usually goes to Democratic or to donors
in general at it sounds like pretty
standard nepotism to me obviously Jesse
threw a lot out there and I say if it is
all true lock them up right I mean
that's the only appropriate thing to do
if he is a mob boss if these are the
corleones and not the bidens then that's
where you have to go with this but it
still hasn't been proven and but nobody
will investigate it
you literally have not investigate this
you have tapes that we can hear you have
informants that are Chinese spies no you
have a retired Navy Lieutenant Bob
olinsky oh right the guy right who does
the cable news interviews right oh on
our station yeah pause interviews on
CNBC or MSNBC no I'm
I'm just saying and Chuck grassley's
been clear about this and Ron Johnson
has been clear about this when pushed by
responsible anchors that they do not
have it yet they are working on it
that's what Kevin McCarthy's doing he's
doing the war working on it tour but
what he's not telling the viewers at
home is that there are 18 Republicans
that were elected in Democratic
districts who are not going to go for an
impeachment so you're not going to get
it all right you know what I also just
quickly on Dana's point about what Peter
Baker pointed out and Democrats will
remind you of this the New York Times
was responsible for getting Hillary's
email server Scandal out there and
uranium one so it's not like we think
that they are that was coming out with
Uma abington's husband they had the
laptop they didn't do any favor here
that's what I'm saying is that the New
York Times doesn't help Democrats all
the time they ended up breaking all
right they're yelling at me they are
yelling at me who are they I don't know
they're weird I've never met them I
don't know who the heck they are I went
on Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now